something which sometimes comes up
question which comes up regarding um
whether or not it'sa is something which
is solely a practice during the last 10
days of Ramadan or not is it as far as
e being done only in the last 10 days of
Ramadan it is not a must since as I
mentioned is voluntary unless we make a
w it's a
Sunnah it can be done in any day of the
year
but according to IMI he says the best is
when you're fasting that's the month of
Ramadan and the best day in the month of
Ramadan is the last 10 days so the best
preferable days are the last 10 days of
Ramadan but you can do any other day of
Ramadan any other day of the year and
when was asked this question that can be
done any day or only in the last 10 days
of Ramadan he G the same reply that it
is preferable it is must it's encouraged
to do eth off in the last 10 days of
Ramadan because of seeking otherwise it
can be done any day of Ramadan any day
of the year it's mentioned in say bukari
Vol number eight in the book of Oaths
and vows Hadith number
6697 with him in the days of ignorance
in before he accepted Islam he had vowed
that he would
do for one night in the mjid Haram and
the prophet said full F that
means with him he did in one of the
nights any night of the year it further
mentioned in say
Muslim volume number two in the book of
fasting Hadith number 2641 that the
prophet for the first 10 days of shaal
it's mentioned in s Muslim volume number
two in the book of fasting Hadith number
2627 that the prophet Dida for the full
month of Ramadan the first 10 days of
Ramadan then the middle 10 days then the
last 10
days it's further mentioned in say
bukari volume number three in the book
OFA Hadith number
2044 that the prophet Dida for 20 days
in the month of Ramadan before he died
that means the last time did just before
he died last Raman of his life he Dida
for the last 20 days
and it's mentioned that because
Archangel Gabriel he rehearsed with him
the Quran twice therefore for 20 days
and it's mentioned in s bukari Vol
number three in the book of had number
2026 that the prophet used to do for the
last 10 days of Ramadan and after he
died his wife continued with the
practice so it indicates that doinga in
the last 10 days it's preferable it's
the best otherwise you can do in any
other day of Ramadan any other day of
you is Doctor